COACH JEFF BOWLS IN HIS
SECOND SEASON WITH THE
BOBCATS FORMER PLAYER FOR
OHIO AS WELL. KIND ENOUGH TO
JOIN US. NOW. WHAT ARE WE FOR
HOURS COACH FROM FROM TIP-OFF?
YEAH, THREE HOURS AND
49 MINUTES TO BE EXACT EVERY
HOURS AND 49 MINUTES FOR OHIO
GETTING READY TO TAKE ON
CREIGHTON OHIO, OF COURSE
ALREADY TAKING DOWN THE
DEFENDING NATIONAL CHAMPION,
VIRGINIA CAVALIERS FIRST OFF
COACH. CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE YOU'RE PLAYING WITH
HOUSE MONEY. I KNOW YOU WANT
TO KEEP IT GOING BUT WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE WIN OVER UVA. YEAH.
THANK YOU. JUST REALLY PROUD
OF OUR GUYS AND THEIR MINDSET
COMING IN. YOU KNOW, THEY
BELIEVE THEY
AND I TOLD HIM AFTER THE GAME
THE POWER OF BELIEF THE POWER
OF BELIEF THE POWER OF
BELIEF THE POWER OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE POWER UNITY
IS SPECIAL AND YOU KNOW,
WE'VE BEEN UNDERDOGS FOR
ABOUT YOU KNOW, THREE
STRAIGHT GAMES NOW MAC
TOURNAMENT INCLUDED AND OUR
GUYS JUST KEEP FINDING THE
WAY. WHAT ARE YOU GUYS A FOUR
SEED GOING INTO THE
TOURNAMENT AND THE MAC? WE'RE
5C IS A LITTLE DECEPTIVE
BECAUSE WE HAD TO COVID
PAUSES WHERE WE MISSED A
BUNCH OF GAMES. SO WE
FINISHED NINE AND FIVE TOLEDO
WON THE LEAGUE AT 14 AND 4
SO THEY HAD FOUR LOSSES AKRON
AND CAN'T HAVE LIKE FIVE.
LOSSES BUFFALO AT 6:00 AND WE
WERE 9 AND 5 AND WE MISSED A
LOT OF OUR GAMES. SO WE
THOUGHT GOING IN WE COULD WIN
THE TOURNAMENT. WE HAVE THE
TALENT TO DO IT AND WE END UP
LEADING A HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
OUT OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
MINUTES AND ALL THREE GAMES.
WOW. YEAH, THE COVID YOU HAD
EIGHT GAMES CANCELLED. I
BELIEVE THREE POSTPONED AND
THEN YOU HAD THE LONGEST
PAUSE WAS ALMOST THREE WEEKS
RIGHT IN FEBRUARY.
YEAH, IT WAS A CRAZY TIME
WITH 21 DAYS. WE PLAYED ON
FEBRUARY 2ND AND WE HAD
MULTIPLE POSITIVE TESTS
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF A
WEEK. SO WE HAD DIFFERENT
GUYS COMING BACK DIFFERENT
TIMES AND WE HAD NINE GUYS
AVAILABLE ON A SUNDAY BEFORE
WE PLAY THAT WEEK THREE GAMES
AND FIVE DAYS. SO WE DIDN'T
EVEN DO A REAL 5V5 PRACTICE.
WE THREW A MANAGER IN THERE
IS THE AS A TENTH GUY AND
THEN WE PLAYED TUESDAY
AGAINST AKRON WITHOUT JASON
PRESTON'S WHITE WILSON
BEAT.
THEN WE PLAY THURSDAY AGAINST
EASTERN MICHIGAN WON THAT
GAME AND THEN WE PLAYED
BUFFALO AND SATURDAY AND LOST
THAT GAME AND THEN WE HAVE
ANOTHER POSITIVE TEST THAT
WEEKEND AND OUR LAST TWO
REGULAR SEASON GAMES WERE
CANCELLED. SO GOING INTO THE
MAC TOURNAMENT. WE'D ONLY
TAKE THREE TIMES IN ABOUT 35
DAYS. THAT'S INCREDIBLE. WELL
WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE
SHORT-HANDED LIKE THAT, DOES
IT EVER CROSS YOUR MIND? I
THINK YOU'RE AROUND MY AGE.
YOU PLAYED IT, OHIO WITH WITH
GARY TRENT YOU EVER JUMP IN
THERE YOURSELF IN THE FIVE
AND FIVE.
IF I WANT TO BUILD THE
CONFIDENCE UP MY GUYS I JUMP
IN THERE. I THINK YOU KNOW,
IT WAS DIFFERENT. YEAH. I
CALLED MICHIGAN'S ASSISTANCE,
YOU KNOW, THEY WERE ON A 14
BAY PAUSE AND THERE'S WAS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE POSITIVE TEST. SO WE DID
CONDITIONING AND INDIVIDUAL
WORKOUTS FOR THE FIRST COUPLE
DAYS. THERE'S SOME HALF-COURT
STUFF ON THE THIRD DAY GAVE
HIM OFF THE FOURTH DAY JUST
TO RECOVER AND THEN THAT
FIFTH DAY THAT SUNDAY WE
TRIED TO GO GO 5V5 UP AND
DOWN WITH A MANAGER IN THERE.
BUT IT WAS DEFINITELY
DIFFERENT. I'LL GIVE OUR
GUY'S A TON OF CREDIT.
THEY'RE RESILIENT, YOU KNOW,
WE PREACH YOU KNOW E + R
EQUALS O EVENT PLUS RESPONSE
HE GOES OUTCOME AND THEIR
RESPONSE TO EVERYTHING WAS
JUST AWESOME. YEAH, IT'S IT
HAS BEEN AWESOME TO WATCH YOU
GUYS. DO WHAT YOU'VE DONE
TAKEN DOWN UVA DAN HALLY WITH
THE HEAD COACH OF THE OHIO
BOBCATS, JEFF BULLS TRYING TO
GET INTO THE SWEET 16 THEY
PLAY CREIGHTON COMING UP
HERE IN JUST A FEW HOURS
COACH. I HAVE TO ASK YOU
YOU IT'S WELL.
COMMANDED BY NOW, BUT I HAVE
TO ADMIT PRIOR TO THE
TOURNAMENT. I WAS NOT
FAMILIAR WITH JSON PRESTON
STORY AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY
FASCINATING TO READ ABOUT A
GUY WHO WAS A SENIOR AT
BOONE HIGH SCHOOL IN ORLANDO
WHO DIDN'T PLAY MUCH AN
AVERAGE TWO POINTS A GAME AND
WANTED TO BE A WANTED TO DO
WHAT WE'RE DOING. HE WANTED
TO BE A SPORTS JOURNALIST. HE
WAS BLOGGING ABOUT THE
PISTONS AND WENT TO UCF FOR
SUMMER SCHOOL. THEN GOT
SPOTTED IT AN AAU TOURNAMENT
AND IT TOTALLY CHANGED HIS
ENTIRE COURSE.
OF HIS LIFE. DID YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU WERE GETTING IN?
JASON PRESTON WHEN YOU STEP
YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT HE HAD A
CHANCE TO BE REALLY GOOD AND
WHEN I CAME HERE IT WAS AFTER
HIS FRESHMAN YEAR. HE
AVERAGED ABOUT FIVE AND A
HALF POINTS A GAME. AND YOU
KNOW, HE WAS ABOUT 6 3 170
WHEN I GOT THERE AND HE GREW
AN INCH THAT SUMMER AND
GAINED ABOUT 20 POUNDS OF
MUSCLE AND LIKE HIS STORY IS
THE AMERICAN DREAM. LIKE I
TELL PEOPLE ALL THE TIME.
IT'S A MOVIE AND IF YOU
REALLY GO BACK AND LISTEN TO
EVERY DETAIL
THE DECISIONS THAT HE MADE TO
GET TO WHERE HE IS LIKE ONE
DECISION THAT HE MADE
DIFFERENTLY LIKE IF HE DIDN'T
WANT TO PLAY AN AAU
TOURNAMENT WITH HIS BUDDIES.
IT'S PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
NEVER HAPPENED. YOU KNOW,
IT'S LIKE HE FORGOT HIS SHOES
WHEN HE WAS ON THE WAY TO THE
TO THE MILK HOUSE IN ORLANDO
AND HAD TO GO BACK AND GET
THEM, YOU KNOW, THEN THERE'S
FAMILY WANTED TO STAY
ENROLLED AT CENTRAL FLORIDA
AND HE GOES TO PREP SCHOOL
JUST SO MANY DECISIONS THAT
LOSING THE
AND IN WHERE HE'S AT TODAY,
JUST YOU KNOW, I CANNOT BE
PROUD OF HIM. JUST AN
INCREDIBLE STORY LOST HIS MOM
IS JUNIOR YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL
DIDN'T REALLY GET ALONG GREAT
WITH HIS HIGH SCHOOL COACH
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE HIGH
SCHOOL COACH DIDN'T LIKE HIS
JUMP PASSES, WHICH IS WHAT HE
DOES. SO WELL, THEY ACTUALLY
CHANGE THE RULE AT OHIO. THIS
IS BEFORE YOU WERE THERE TO
ALLOW JUMP PASSES WHEN WHEN
JASON PRESTON GOT THERE
BECAUSE HE JUST KIND OF HAD A
KNACK FOR MAKING THINGS
HAPPEN AND NOW HE'S A
LEGITIMATE
.
HEY PROSPECT, WHO IS HELPING?
YOU GUYS TRY TO GET TO THE
SWEET 16 COACH. HOW ABOUT A
SCOUTING REPORT ON CREIGHTON?
AND I WHAT WHEN YOU'RE
PUTTING STUFF UP ON THE
WHITEBOARD, WHAT ARE THE
THREE KEYS TO THE GAME FOR
YOU? YEAH, I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT THEIR OFFENSE, YOU
KNOW, VERY DYNAMIC OFFENSE IN
OUR OFFENSE IN THEIR OFFENSE
AND OUR TEAM. THEY'RE ALMOST
MIRROR IMAGE, YOU KNOW FIVE
GUYS IN DOUBLE FIGURES. THEY
SHOOT THE BALL AT A 37 38
PERCENT CLIP, YOU KNOW, 45%
OF SHOTS WITH THREES, AND
JUST HAVE GREAT BALANCE 18:11
OVER A SHOW.
WE REALLY GOT TO DO A GOOD
JOB TRANSITION. THEY DO A
PHENOMENAL JOB PUSHING THE
BALL AND THEY HAVE FOUR
SHOOTERS OUT THERE THAT CAN
MAKE THREE. SO WE GOT TO BE
COGNIZANT OF THAT AND YOU
KNOW, ONE OF OUR BREAD AND
BUTTER IS ALL YEARS THAN
PAINT TOUCHES AND POST
TOUCHES. SO WE HAVE TO TRY TO
GET THE BALL INSIDE ON
OFFENSE AND AND YOU KNOW, WE
KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO TRAP
THE BALL SCREENS WITH JASON
AND WE JUST GOT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT. I'M SO
CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
ESSENTIALLY INSIDE THAT THAT
THE TOURNAMENT. I'M ASSUMING
GUYS HAD A SHOOT AROUND
YESTERDAY OR
NOT TO OVER SCHEDULE BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO KEEP THEM THEIR
MINDS ACTIVE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAH, SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THEN GAVIN IS STAFF HAVE DONE
A PHENOMENAL JOB OF TRYING TO
YOU KNOW, NUMBER ONE GET TO
THIS WEEKEND. AND YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE THE ONE HECK UP WITH
VCU, BUT THEY'VE DONE A GREAT
JOB OF KIND OF SEPARATING
ICELAND EVERYBODY AND BEING
CAREFUL. YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
YOUR NORMAL I GUESS INTO WA
EXPERIENCE FROM A PLAYER'S
STANDPOINT, BUT OUR GUYS THAT
WATCH THE GAMES AND WE HAVE A
MEETING ROOM. THEY HAVE A
BUNCH OF PRACTICE COURTS IN
THE CONVENTION CENTER WHERE
YOU DO YOUR SHOOT AROUND IN
YOUR PRACTICES, SO THEY'VE
DONE A GOOD JOB.
YOU KNOW TRY TO STAY FOCUSED
YOU PLAYED IT, OHIO. YOU GUYS
WENT TO THE TOURNAMENT BACK
ONE OF THAT GARY TRENT TEAM.
I BELIEVE WAS 95 96 MORE
STRESS MORE PRESSURES A
PLAYER AS A COACH.
NOTHING IS A PLAYER, YOU KNOW,
BUT BACK THEN, YOU KNOW, YOU
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT YOU DIDN'T
KNOW AND YOU KNOW TODAY WAS
THE SOCIAL MEDIA AND
ATTENTION. EVERYONE'S GETTING
YOU KNOW, OUR GUYS HAVE BEEN
A LOOSE BUNCH IN A FUN-LOVING
BUNCH. THEY BUILT THEY LOVE
EACH OTHER AND YOU KNOW
BEFORE WE PLAYED THE MAC
TOURNAMENT THAT ONE GUY
PLAYED THE MAC TOURNAMENT UP
IN CLEVELAND BEFORE SO THEY
WENT INTO THAT TOURNAMENT,
YOU KNOW WITH WITH, YOU KNOW,
JUST TO LOSE MENTALITY, YOU
KNOW BEFORE THE CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME. THEY'RE IN THERE LISTEN
TO MUSIC LAUGHING AND TALKING
AND I WAS ELATED TO HEAR
THAT AND IT WAS
THE SAME FEEL
COMING INTO THIS TOURNAMENT,
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T HAVE THE
SAME HOOPLA WHICH EVERYONE
WALKING AROUND IN THE OPEN
PRACTICE OF THE FANS. SO WHEN
WE GET THERE, YOU KNOW IS
MAYBE 1500 PEOPLE IN THE
ARENA A LOT OF BOBCATS AND IT
WAS ALMOST LIKE ANOTHER GAME
FOR OUR GUYS. THAT'S AWESOME
II LOVE TO THE STORY THAT I
READ ABOUT YOUR YOUR GROUP
TEXT THAT YOU HAVE WITH ALL
THOSE GUYS THAT YOU PLAYED IN
THAT NCAA TOURNAMENT WITH DO
THEY KEEP YOU GROUNDED ALL
SPECIAL
GROUP, YOU KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND COUPLE OF THEM ARE
GOING TO BE HERE TONIGHT. AND
YOU KNOW, IT'S YOU KNOW,
THERE'S THERE'S NO BETTER
FEELING THAN BEING ON A TEAM
THAT CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM YOU'RE
BONDED FOR LIFE AND YOU
ALWAYS HAVE A CONNECTION, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN
EACH OTHER'S WEDDINGS AND
REUNIONS AND AND WE HAVE A
TEXT CHAIN LIKE WE'RE IN THE
LOCKER ROOM YESTERDAY ON THE
BUS TRIP YESTERDAY CRACKING
JOKES. AND LIKE I SAID,
THERE'S NO NO ONE'S SAFE. YOU
KNOW ME INCLUDED WE PLAYED IN
INDIANA AND THEY TRIPLE TEAM
GARY TRENT AND LEFT ME AND
GINA FORD WIDE OPEN.
I WAS THREE FOUR.
AND GINA WAS 149 AND ONE OF
MY TEAMMATES AFTER THE GAME
CAME UP TO ME AND SAID HEY
YOU GOING TO SLEEP HERE
TONIGHT? I SAID, WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT? HE'S LIKE THAT
BRICK HOUSE YOU BUILT AT THE
TOP OF THE KEY BRICK YOU
THREW UP AND BUT LOVE THOSE
GUYS AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THEY'VE DONE FOR
ME AND THEIR SUPPORT LAST
QUESTION BEFORE WE LET YOU GO
DAN HALEY FILLING IN FOR RICH
EISEN WITH JEFF BULLS THE
HEAD COACH AT OHIO UNIVERSITY
GETTING READY TO TAKE ON
CREIGHTON HERE AND JUST A
COUPLE OF HOURS. SO KIND OF
JOIN US VERY GENEROUS OF YOU
I KNOW YOU GOT A LOT GOING ON
YOU SET THIS FOUNDATION LAST
SEASON WITH A TRIP TO DAIRY
QUEEN. IS THAT RIGHT? YEAH,
WE LOST. I THINK FIVE GAMES
IN A ROW AND THEY WERE ALL
CLOSE GAMES AND OUR GUYS YOU
CAN JUST TELL THEY'RE
DEFLATED AFTER THE GAME AND
SOON AS WE STARTED PULLING
OUT. I REMEMBER THERE WAS A
DAIRY QUEEN ON THE WAY IN I
TOLD THE BUS DRIVER DEAD.
A DETOUR. WE'RE GOING TO
DAIRY QUEEN AND WENT TO THE
BACK OF THE BUS AND TOLD THE
BOYS. WE'RE GOING TO GET SOME
BLIZZARDS BECAUSE ICE CREAM
MAKES
ONE PUT A SMILE ON THEIR FACE
AND JUST A LIGHT-HEARTED
MOMENT, YOU KNOW LOSING STUFF
WINNINGS HARD AND YOU HAVE
TO ENJOY THE UPS AND DOWNS
AND AND JUST SOMETHING TO PUT
SMILE ON THEIR FACE AND IT
WORKED. THAT'S AWESOME. HEY
JEFF. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. WE HAD PETER KING,
OHIO ALUM ON RIGHT BEFORE
YOU I KNOW YOU'VE TEXTED WITH
HIM. HE'S DEFINITELY WISHING
YOU. GOOD LUCK AS WELL. YEAH.
PETER WAS AWESOME. WE HAD A
GREAT CONVERSATION HERE AT
NIGHT. IT WAS SO MANY BOBCAT
ALUMNI OUT THERE AND THE
VERSITY WHAT THIS IS MEANT
FOR THEM AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
KEEP IT GOING IT IS A
CINDERELLA STORY.
HE PLAYED IT OHIO. HE IS NOW
COACHING OHIO TRYING TO GET
THEM INTO THE SWEET 16 THEY
PLAY CREIGHTON COMING UP IN
JUST A COUPLE OF HOURS GEOFF
THANKS FOR JOINING US. GOOD
GUYS.